Vladimir Putin announced he's running
for re-election as president of Russia
yeah yeah Putin's campaign slogan is I
made America great again
yeah what do I have the feeling he's
gonna win by like 90 percent of the vote
yeah why don't we start messing with his
election yes I'm gonna get on the
internet and be an anti-putin troll yeah
I just got to learn Russian yeah gotta
learn Russian yeah and they'll kill you
the only problem with yeah that's got
about that what I was going on yesterday
it's interesting First Lady Melania
Trump and second lady Karen pence
visited Texas yeah that's right baby is
it sexist nice yeah Melania was
overheard saying we're near the border
let's make a run for it let's get out of
here hey they're like Thelma and Louise
yeah look it up it's a good reference
during a speech on TV yesterday
President Trump was heard slurring I
know if you saw that yes Larry yeah
Trump tonight it said I save all my
slurs for Muslims so
yeah I like that Allah who's and then
sort of a grudging respect at the end
[Music]
the FDA that's the Food and Drug
Administration Andy that is true yeah
[Laughter]
you can't bottle this chemistry you can
again just can't the FDA has approved a
new drug that fights both diabetes and
obesity both diabetes and obesity yeah
yeah yeah when they heard this Dunkin
Donuts said oh [ __ ] it is on Ireland in
the news Ireland will be collecting
fifteen billion dollars from Apple in a
settlement over back taxes fifteen
billion dollars for Ireland yeah yeah
Ireland will receive the money on Friday
and Guinness will have it all by Monday
trust me I'm allowed to do that joke
okay I'm really allowed a New York woman
is suing her surgeon claiming he was on
his cell phone during her operation yeah
in response the doctor said for your
information I was googling how to
perform surgery yeah that's all I was
doing oh okay
Amazon is now making it possible to
create a shopping profile for your cat
yeah all you have to do is go to Amazon
and type in I am single and
why do that I have three cats no no I
you